l'industrie l'emploi et la jeunesse
étent à l'honneur mercredi 24 janvier à
la Chambre des commerces et d'industrie
des ivelines lors de sa cérémonie des
vux l'organisme a notamment présenté ses
perspectives pour la nouvelle année 2024
pour créer davantage d'entreprises dans
le territoire il faut des ambassadeurs
il faut les entreprises industrielles on
est dans un territoire d'industrie et il
faut les entreprises qui puissent
innover donc on a voilà de jeunes
ingénieurs de jeunes scientifiques on
vise plus de 30000 création entreprise
dans not territoire pour 2024 plus de
300 institutionnels chefs d'entreprise
et jeunes porteurs de projet étit
rassemblé à l'Hôtel Du Barry de
Versailles parmi eux Sébastien Rogon
directeur des ressources humaines du
site de production Renault affelin pour
qu' l'année 2024 sera notamment consacré
à l'embauche nous avons d'ors et déjà
annoncé que l'année 2024 serait le début
d'un cycle qui nous verrait passer à 150
nouveaux emplois en CDI pour accompagner
la croissance de la refactory et ses
nouvelles activités le site de la
refactory de Flin pour Renault group ça
représente un enjeu nouveau autour du
thème de l'économie circulaire de la
mobilité et c'est aussi un élément qui
est majeur pour les nouvelles
générations et donc à ce titre nous
souhaitons parler aux nouvelles
générations et attirer les nouveaux
talents l'économie circulaire un enjeu
également fondamental pour hugoline
solaire fondatrice de renorec basé à
traap la start-up transforme les
plastiques orphelins de solution de
recyclage en un mat solide et écologique
qui se travaille comme du bois 2024
c'est une année extraordinaire pour nous
c'est l'année du décollage c'est l'année
du démarrage de la production
industrielle attendu depuis un certain
temps donc là en janvier on démarre on a
l'ambition de sauver 100 tonnes de
déchelin cette année avant de pouvoir
multiplier les impacts et les
territoires d'implantation en 2023 la
chambre des commerces et d'industrie des
ivelines a accompagné près de 25800
entreprises et 8400 établissements